Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill bird.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, June 6th,
2016 this is like the fifth fucking time
I've tried to start this thing because,
uh, I dunno, I just had an aborted
landing. Well, I didn't have one.
The pilot had one and a, I was
riding in the back and, you know,
what are you going to do? What
we landed safely, you know,
some airplane didn't clear the runway.
That was my fifth one that I've had.
I've had five aborted landings and
that was my second one at lax. Um,
first one was vehicle on a runway
and this next one, a guy didn't,
a plane was still on the runway. It
didn't clear it or whatever, but uh,
it was a little less scary. Now
that I've flown a little bit,
you know, not a lot, but
a little bit, but, uh,
you're still in the back and you
can't see what's going on. So that's,
that's always nice. Um, all right.
So people have been asking
me, they've been emailing me,
they'd been twittering me,
they'd been Facebooking me. Um,
about what's going on with
these Irish dates? Uh,
Dublin July 31st Belfast
August 1st and Galloway,
Galway, modal Ireland
on the 2nd of August.
All right. I have the presale information,
but for whatever reason I'm not allowed
to announce it, but I'm going to,
I'll tell you what, I'm going to announce
it. I'm gonna announce it on six,
nine, 16 at 4:00 PM GMT
time, whatever that means.
Gaelic Gaelic Mountain. [inaudible]
Haiti tool time. All right. Um,
why can't I just say when the fuck
this shit's going to be all right.
June 10th is when that going on sale.
I'll announce the presale on
the ninth hour. Fuck this.
I'm going to tell you everything now.
All right. Six nine, 16 at 4:00 PM, uh,
the presale will be announced. No, right.
Just this is why I had to rerecord
it. This is so fucking confusing.
The presale for Dublin, Ireland is
going to be June 10th. My birthday,
2016 at 9:00 AM Gaelic
mountain time. All right.
Um, and then the regular on
sale is going to be June 13th,
9:00 AM GMT time, whatever the
fuck that means. Alright. And, um,
Belfast is going to be about five days
later and so's Gallway a gay away modal
Ireland. Um, we'll be
like, that'll be June 15th.
MMM. [inaudible]
so that's the deal. All right. And
I'll let you guys know. I'll just,
I'll tweet about it.
I'll do all that shit so nobody
gets fucked out of anything. Also,
there's been a second show
added in London, England,
um,
for August six, 2016 a we'll have a link
up there for that and I'll let shit,
all right. There you go.
I got all the business stuff out of
the way and also go to all things,
comedy.com be sick of listening to me.
We got a bunch of other talented people
out there that you can listen to. Um,
and with that, let's get
into the podcast. Oh, did I?
Around SCIATICA. It's still acting up.
I'm going to every fucking witch
doctor out here at this point.
I don't give a shit. You know,
some woman was talking to me was saying
how she got Sciatica when she was
pregnant and it was just like, he
called me fat and she, she laughed.
She's like, no, she goes, I
just, I just got it. And uh,
she went someplace and she goes,
they just kinda lightly
just with on my backside.
I thought they were really
gonna need in there.
They just kinda lightly wants like what?
That nobody's fucking putting
leaves on my butt cheeks.
I'm going to go to everybody
else first before that. Um,
but I gotta tell you like
something happens with the
air pressure when I'm on a
plane, the back of my leg, it feels
like my hamstrings gonna snap. Uh,
so I got to keep standing up doing my
Vietnamese gambler fucking squat and um,
I dunno. I'm trying to
stretch out the PSOAS muscle.
I'm doing everything I can to try to
keep this thing at bay cause I don't
fucking have the time to take care of it.
I just don't have to
fucking busy here with, uh,
writing this filthy wonderful cartoon,
which I'm having a great time doing.
I bopped episode six this week. People
up to episode six writing as far,
far as that aspect of it. I literally
signed to fucking Raymond. All right,
let me take you through my trip here.
All right. I had some fucking guy,
he was like in his early sixties give
me this fucking look like he was gonna
Punch me in the face to the point
I had to say something to him.
And I know you guys are
thinking like, Bill,
what the fuck you're talking shit to a
guy 63 well I'm going to be 48 this week.
So you know when I was 15 he
was 30 so it's not that bad.
We're pretty close, right?
When I was 10 he was 25 right.
But you know,
you think he wouldn't have picked on
me back then is what happened. Right?
So I went down, go around
in the airport, right?
I got bumped up the business.
So I get to go first.
I get to go into the lounge, right?
I get to go in and fucking pour
myself some cornflakes or whatever.
So I go into the lounge and there's this
fucking guy, right. He just, I dunno,
I just, I got on the elevator and he was
there and he was kind of in my space,
but he was a little
oblivious or whatever. Right.
Fucking horseshoe level
bald and he dies the sides,
which is always hysterical
to me. Like, dude,
what the why you still dying that you
think that makes you look younger? Um,
so anyways, it's like five in the
fucking was before five in the morning.
Cause that's what time my
flight is. And you know,
I go up to the lounge and I set my
shit down. He goes his other way.
I'm not even thinking about this guy.
And then I'm walking over to where
the cereal is and so is he all right?
Like two planes about to land,
you know, on the same runway.
I'm in front of them, I have priority.
So I walk over there and then he,
I feel him standing way
close to close to me.
And when I finished, you know, I
just did a couple of turns, you know,
the fucking Ciro thing.
Couple turns of the KNOB,
it goes into the bowl and
then I pour some milk in it.
It probably took me less than 15 seconds
to do that. And when I turned around,
cause I just felt him, I would
have turned the other way.
But I felt him on my left shoulder turn
and looked at him and he was glaring at
me showing me all of his bottom
teeth. You know, he's like,
Eh, except he wasn't making that noise.
But you know the face
you make when you eh,
that's what he was looking
at me just glaring at me.
So what the fuck did I say to them?
Okay.
I just looked down, I was like, I
am. I said, are you, I go, you are,
you are right. That's why
I said, are you all right?
And then he didn't say anything.
Yeah.
And then I felt bad like, oh man was,
was he like one of those old guys?
Remember I did that bit.
The old man face was that,
is that the beginning of the old man face?
You start glaring at first and
then you gradually get more scared.
I have no idea. Right. Um,
it's like those old people
know they're going to hell.
They're thinking back on their
life and they're trying to think,
do they have enough time to
say enough hair, Hail Mary's?
And they just realized
they can't. They're like,
they probably saw ghosts and saw those
creepy things coming up from hell.
So anyways, he didn't say anything.
So I walk away and I'm thinking that
feeling bad. Like, aw man, I, I,
I, uh, you know, I just
fucking yelled at that old,
I didn't yell at the old guy, but
I kind of gave him shit, you know,
so I felt bad then went over to sit down
and then he gets his fucking cereal and
at this point, you know, I'm like, I'm
like fucking 20 yards away from this guy,
sit down and he fucking turns around
and as he's walking over to his wife,
he looks at me and goes, hey
man, shakes his fucking head up.
She was glaring at me.
Okay.
So later I go to get up to get a fucking
apple and I knew where he was going to
be looking at him. And I
looked right over at him and I,
I can't remember what the fuck I did.
And then I was like, really, Bill,
are you really doing this? Neither
one of these is going to fight.
You're both too fucking old to fight.
And that's how my trip started.
So I should have known that it was
going to be a weird travel experience.
Um, ended up getting into a Syracuse.
That's what I was going the first night.
And we played this minor
league hockey arena and, uh,
I didn't know at the time until I
got there. They actually, uh, filmed,
um, that's where they filmed slapshot a
lot of it when they did all this stuff,
you know,
I'm listening to the fucking song when
they were on the ice and everything,
so that was cooly shit. Um,
the next night we did another one of those
small hockey arenas and then that one
they told me that was the place
Elvis was supposed to perform at.
Um, but he died the day before.
That was his next concert.
And so they still have all these Elvis
tickets and they actually gave me this
little frame thing of a couple
of Elvis tickets and then a,
the date that I played there
was really fucking cool. Um,
what the fuck did I go after that?
Oh, then I went down to ball.
I was driving from Portland back
to fucking Albany. Who's kidding?
Who I wasn't fucking
[inaudible] was riding.
We were in this SUV and I was laying
down in the back seat because my fucking
leg was killing me. Um, it's shit's
really starting to scare me, man.
Like how fucking long is this gonna take?
I've been dealing with
this shit since February.
Every time I start to turn the corner,
I got to get on a plane again. So
people always stare at me too. When I
stand up on the plane, I squat down.
I don't even give a fuck.
And they just looking at me.
I told you in the last time this
guy asked me if I was praying.
So, um, anyways, in the
final show last night was,
was in Albany, but I actually,
when we drove from Portland,
which so many memories came back
when we went over that bridge,
when we went over this bridge and, uh,
we go from New Hampshire to Maine
and I remember I used to fucking,
one of my first girlfriends used
to live over there. Brandon,
the other side of that,
well, she didn't live there.
She lived down in the Boston area,
but she had like family up there.
I remember going up on over that
bridge. I always think of that shit.
I always think about the ticket that I
got on the fucking turnpike up there,
driving my piece of shit truck back.
Um, the comedy connection up there,
all of that shit. And,
um, I gotta tell you, man,
just living out here in la, lay all
people in New York for Mont New Hampshire,
in Western mass in Maine.
I hope they realize how fucking lucky
they are to live where it rains and
there's all that lush land. I'm
so fucking jealous of that shit.
Like when I came back, um, we would,
when we would drive in from
Portland to, uh, Albany,
I actually went down to the Boston area
to visit some family and friends and
stop off and one of my favorite
pizza places and uh, I,
we can't ended up coming down route
one in them fucking memories that were
coming back.
There was this strip club up there that
was the hilltop steakhouse would say now
completely knocked down.
I hope that signed cause it's
still up that giant fucking cactus.
I hope somehow like
that thing is protected.
You know what I mean?
You know, it's funny.
That's like one of those dumb things
they'll sell on fucking Ebay for like 1
million bucks and it'll say like 15
people are watching this, you know,
do you know like, like back
in the day how they used to,
they used to catch people with
warrants. They would just have a,
like during like a fight or something,
they would just advertise a, hey,
you're the, you're the
20th person to order this.
Come down here and claim your free gift.
And they'd call these people up and they
would all go down and claim the gifts
and then I'll be all these people standing
around down there and then the cops
would just walk in and they'd
fucking arrest everybody. Um,
they should fucking do that with,
with dumb shit like that on Ebay.
Like the giant, the
hilltop steakhouse, right?
There's 15 people watching it.
Those 15 people should immediately
be audited. Who would have,
who do Fox got 1 million bucks to
blow on a giant lit up cat. I mean,
everybody wants it. Well, not everybody.
I'd love to have that fucking thing.
You know, get yourself to spread
out in the middle of nowhere.
You have a giant lit up cactus.
Your friends come over, right?
Just to make a right at
the giant cactus. You know,
you get a nickname out of it. Oh,
cactus Chris, he's fucking crazy.
Um,
but nobody has the money to do that shit.
Right? Like I went on Ebay,
right? And I was, uh, I don't,
what the fuck I was looking, I was
trying to, you know, kill the flight now.
Now you can, you know, go online. So I
was just looking up random shit like, uh,
humidors even though I've gotten
cigars mostly out of my life,
I was just looking him up cause I
think they're fucking cool. Right.
Well I know what I was doing,
I was looking at cigar aficionado
and they had all these, you know,
cool places where you can smoke a cigar.
They let you know in different cities
like places to smoke and shit. Right?
Like I already find a cool place in
London, um, possibly to smoke. We'll see.
And uh, that is if I smoked there, I
don't know, we'll figure it out anyways.
Uh, and that just got me thinking about
cigar smoking and all that type of shit.
So I went on Ebay and a lot of the shit
that comes along with cigar smoke and
it's pretty fucking cool.
A lot of the lighters,
a lot of the ash trays in the humidors
and I like looking at that stuff,
especially if they're vintage or
old. So I look up vintage humidor.
I'm sure it's still there. And
this, this does this fucking,
I think it's sitting bull.
It's this bust of sitting bull.
All right. That's what
the fucking humidor is.
It's a bust of sitting bull and
what's really fucking, you know,
weird is to to, you know,
put your cigars in it.
You basically take off the scalp, which
I thought was a little fucking tacky,
but granted it's old. That
was considered a Mike.
Totally fine back in the
day. Right? Um, so anyways,
this fucking thing is going for
a million and a half dollars
and it has, it says like
there's like 20 people watching.
I'm looking it up right
now. ebay.com. All right.
Okay. Vintage you mid door. Boom.
All right. What do you got?
What do you got? Oh fuck.
Where the hell is it coming? Oh
there it is. Right there sitting
both cigar store, Indian statue,
Antique American folk art,
vintage tobacco. You know
what's funny from the side?
It actually looks cool from
straight on. It just looks like,
okay.
I Dunno. It's kind of looking off vague.
He kind of looks sad and then they,
I don't understand why.
Okay.
This thing is a million and a half bucks.
This 61 people watching this 61 people
have a million and a half dollars to
spend on a fucking humidor. I Dunno.
Like that's the type of shit right there.
Like if I was dodging and taxes and
all that type of shit, you know,
go out and do this on the Internet.
Right. I Dunno. That's like whenever you,
you, we have watch shows, make
them car auctions. You know,
when somebody spends 500
grand on a fucking Mustang,
I mean, you're either, you're either
evading taxes or you're a wife beater,
one or the other. Okay.
You're either cheating the fucking system
or your wife is scared to death is of
you that she, she'll
let you fucking do that.
Blow a million and a half bucks
on a humidor looking at Ani
and a great setting. Paul, look
at the top of his head, comes off
like after a fucking autopsy. Um, anyways,
so I can't remember the hell
I was talking about here. Oh.
So we end up having to just having
this great anytime I work with furry,
we have a great fucking time. Um, when
we were up in Portland after the show,
we had a great time working the, the
uh, the Elvis venue there and um,
we ended up going up to
this bar afterwards and game
three of the Stanley Cup
finals and uh, the UFC
fights were both on it.
Jesus Christ, Dan fucking Anderson.
Do you guys see that knockout?
That was like some Bourne identity shit.
He threw a kick when passed the guy and
then fucking threw an elbow like he was
training in a phone booth. I've
never seen anything like that in run.
Long time ago I saw a few FC
fighter basically throw a left hook,
but he did it with his knee. He
fucking got rocked in their head.
I think it was that guy that used to
call the little bottle a little ball of
hate. The hell is his name. One of my
favorite fighters back then. Right.
He had hair dyed,
like bright red fire engine red and he
got rocked and he started to go down and
the other guy was so
excited to jump on him,
started hitting him that he kind of just
went in with his hands down a little
bit and the fucking guy was
able to regroup and he just,
I can't explain it. He threw it.
He need the guy in their head,
but he like came from the
side. He threw a hook.
This fucking guy went down,
gave him the old right there.
Fred with the left knee, Dan
Anderson, the same fucking thing.
This guy was just,
he was getting punched in the head
repeatedly and everybody in the bars got,
oh right. And I'm yelling
and I actually for once,
cause I don't know shit about fighting.
I go, he's fucking eating those punches.
I'll look at them. And
uh, then next, you know,
he kicks the guy in the fucking head.
He kicked him in the head and then
somehow he was like parallel to the guy's
head and he gave me all that
fucking there with the elbow.
And the guy just went
down. That was it over.
And then the coolest thing ever was his
family was there, you know, tell me,
you don't have the coolest dad ever.
Guy Goes shirtless in the ring,
eats fucking 12 punches to the head
and then knocked the other guy out.
You know, you know, it's funny, he
was in better shape than his kids.
He's a 45 year old guy. You
should have the dad bod.
He's up there shredded. His
kids are coming up, you know,
he's making him look soft. Not saying
they were soft. I'm just saying.
Usually by the time you're
45, you have three, four kids.
You just got that 600 yard stare.
Like you don't give a fuck if you're
eating a twinkie or a fucking tube sock.
You know, and this guys up there just
was shredded. So once again, once again,
UFC
completely worth the fucking
money. Um, the pay to get in.
I missed all the other
fee. Oh No, I saw the uh,
the championship one with a guy there
that I've been watching ever since he was
on, um, the ultimate fighter. The guy
from Manchester, England. Uh, fuck.
I gotta get his name here.
God dammit. Um, I, you know,
I realized when he won, I had been
saying his last name wrong forever.
UFC Champ Manchester.
Here we go. What's his name? Michael
Bisbing. I was, I was Biz Bain.
Michael Bisman. He fucking won.
That was another great one. Um,
what a night. And then as we end,
as we're watching that
simultaneously they watch and uh,
well I guess I was probably the
only one really watching it,
but I was watching the uh,
Penguins San Jose and I'm looking
at this shit going like, holy fuck,
it's two to one that carrying the play
and all of a sudden they get a high
stick. I think it was a
four minute power play.
They seem like they were on the power
play for fucking ever long story short
through up to two to one in
the game. And it was like
they killed off like all, all
fucking 20 minutes of this penalty.
It seems like a 20 minute penalty.
Right? They killed his fucking thing off.
There's like two seconds left.
And all I'm thinking in my head
is if they kill off this penalty,
they're going to win this game
and they're going to win the cup.
This is the fucking series and it's
over three to score out of nowhere.
I Dunno,
I dunno if it was tipped or whatever
after San Jose's goalie made this one of
the sickest, he fucking like saved it
with like the inside of his forearm,
you know, a few minutes earlier
then did any let that one go in
little bit of a floater and now
it's two games to one. Right.
And I don't give a fuck either
way. My team's out of it.
And then my surrogate
team is also a lot of it.
All I know is that means that there's
going to be at least one more game of
hockey.
Right. As far as, rather than just
going for games, that'll go five. Right.
So we at least got two more games,
which is good for me because, uh, when,
when the NHL and the NBA seasons end,
I have like a sort of sports panic attack
because they haven't watched it been
watching baseball. I don't know what
the fuck's going on in baseball,
but all I know it's like the middle
of the season. You know Dahlia,
here's the rubber game. Yes.
Wow. All out Sadie. He going to see that
slat or a lot this afternoon. You know,
after you just went from,
from like watching people win
championships and playing at that level.
Um, that's why the NFL is
the shit as far as like,
it actually compete with October baseball
because you figured that the middle of
the NFL season would be
boring. Like most, most sports,
the middle of this season is boring
when you play in like 80 to 162 gangs.
But NFL only plays 16 games.
Every game means so fucking much,
you know? Um,
yeah.
Plus Tom Brady ought to be coming back
from his nice rest, a nice rest, relaxed,
pissed off. Tom Brady coming back
to light she up again. You know,
you guys can look under the rocks and
try to figure out what he's doing some
day, some day you will admit
that he fucking was, you know,
the guy was just a shit. Um,
and then the saddest thing,
obviously the weekend was a, was
the death of Muhammad Ali. Man,
that guy, if you've never
watched when we were kings,
um,
I used to watch it. I used to own that
thing and I used to, I wore it out.
I had an a VHS then he
had on a DVD. I just,
I've watched it so many
fucking times. I just, um,
I don't even know how to
put the guy into words.
It was literally like one out
of, I watched it, I was like,
I have not done shit with my life.
The guy was unbelievable. And when I,
I tweeted, you know, greatest of all
time, greatest athlete, ambassador,
human being of all time and all these,
you know, Twitter cons, come on bill.
He just, he hit things in a ring.
It's like, no, he didn't, he didn't,
he did so much stuff beyond
that. Like, you know,
it says how great mom and I, Lee was
okay.
Like when I said greatest
human ever, I said, really?
They're like better than Gandhi.
And it's like, exactly. Exactly.
Okay.
If I said fucking Tom Brady,
you know, greatest devil,
you just going to bring
up other quarterbacks.
You had to bring up fucking
Gandhi. This is a goddamn athlete.
That's a good comparison.
Cause he was doing Gandhi shit outside
of the ring and he could knock out
anybody in the world. The guy could
hold court in the poorest of the poor,
right up to the White House. When
he walked in, he lit up the room,
everybody shut up and you never
forgot it. And uh, and on top of that,
he was one of the greatest fighters
of all time, if not the greatest,
um, [inaudible]
and I got so much out of when
I used to watch that, you know,
when he was talking all that shit,
um,
it was like he was almost, as much
as he was talking shit, he was like,
it was like self help.
It's not the way it's done today
where today it's just all like,
it's all perverted. You
know what I mean? It's like,
you know what's going to happen
if you say the crazy shit,
you know that you're hype in the fight,
you know that you're going
to get a sneaker deal.
You know all this money's coming.
I'm not saying that he didn't
know that on some level,
but the shit that that guy went through,
um,
if you watch some of those early,
especially the ones that
are in black and white,
the fucking white reporters are so
God damn racist. It's like ridiculous.
I remember he,
he just going and going and going and
this reporter's just white guys getting
fucking mad. He just hates
his confidence. This guy,
like if this guy could've got sent into
the future, he'd be a hater on Twitter.
So he finally just goes, do,
do you ever stop talking?
And Ali said something like, now,
cause I'm knocking out all
bumps and if you keep talking,
I'm knocking you out too. And
he just, it was the greatest.
He just fucking pissed the guy off and
he knew what the guy was doing and he was
able to navigate all that.
I know everybody says all the terrible
shit that he did to Joe Frazier,
but nobody gets out of this
life without some bad shit.
Everybody's done some bad shit.
You know what I mean? But, um,
I dunno man, he still had a good
run though, 70, 74 years. Um,
I used to watch them when I was a
kid. Man, that's how fucking old I am.
That's what's freaking me out now.
It was all these people that were like
in their twenties and thirties when I was
a kid are now dying of like fucking
old age and shit. David Bowie,
Muhammad Ali,
that's fucking freaking me
out. You know what I mean?
Maybe that's why that guy at the, uh,
at the little cereal thing in the
fucking at the airport was giving me that
look. Cause he knows
he's going. So you know,
everybody he knew is
probably all dead right.
And He's thinking Alan got so much
time left to get cereal. You know,
I was also thinking the fact
that he felt so fucking like he,
the little like the complete lack of
patients that he had and I don't have
patients,
the fact that that he couldn't wait
two seconds for me to get some fucking
cheerio's I was also thinking like
that's probably why he's in this lounge.
This guy just fucking take it doesn't
take no for an answer. He's a lunatic.
Um, I don't know.
That's kind of fucking depressing
shit that'd be talking about death.
Cause I gotta tell you though, man,
like the amount of fucking people that
have died in the last God damn year,
that I am old enough to have been a
teenager and seeing them in their fucking
prime. Um, how about that print shit? Huh?
A person lost to the opiates and
stuff. I just can't put my like,
I can't believe it,
but the fact that they actually come at
him and they come at fame and celebrity
and all that type of shit.
Like people are fucking dying.
Regular people are dying because of
their drug. However the fuck you say,
fentanyl or whatever the
hell it is, they get it.
Then the prescription runs out,
they're addicted to opiates
and then they get on heroin.
And the fact that they don't talk about
the pharmaceutical companies at all is
because that's like 150 fucking zillion
dollar business and they give money to
the politicians and the advertise on TV.
So they make like prints
out to be like this.
Um, this famous guy that P, you know,
nobody could say no to. I
mean, I might be wrong in this,
but I know he had at least one hip if
not two. And if you ever watched the guy,
the guy never took a show off. He
was all over the fucking stage.
I imagine he was in pain and that's
how that shit started was basically him
pouring his heart out on
stage, giving everybody 100%.
He wore out his fucking hips. What's
this? James Brown did the same thing.
He had to get new hips. Um,
fortunately by the time
prince got the operation,
hopefully they were further
along and, uh, but I,
I imagine he still had all kinds of pain.
And then I, I that's, that's my guess,
but for the fact that people
came at him, some people,
the way that they came at him was, uh,
I don't know, considering the shows and,
and the music that he left us. I
thought it was really fucking, ah,
it's a little below the
belt though. When you say I,
I think that's a little below the belt.
Have you guys seen this youtube video?
My name is John Dacre. You
gotta Watch this thing.
I apologize cause it's going to be in
your fucking head for the rest of time.
I'll, I'll, I'll post the, um, the video,
um, to, um, my, my Twitter
account. He's singing,
he's singing a moray and he
can't remember how to say
[inaudible].
Those will ring
the bell more rarely.
I can't stop watching this
guy, this guy, I swear to God,
I think it's his first TV
Gig. Somebody was sick.
I think they said at the beginning, this
guy fills in and if you look at him,
he's literally having an
outer body experience.
So it's so funny to me because I can
relate to this person because the first
time I did stand up I felt
like I was watching myself.
I've fucked everything up and this
guy, just the way he says his name,
it's almost the just, he says like,
my name is John Dacre.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's like, it's like he was outsets.
I think that might be my favorite part
of the video is the when this fucking
guy, just the way he says his own name,
he didn't say, my name's John Dacre.
He goes, my name's John Dagger.
I did it right the first time.
I just fucked it up. Hey, you got to
hear this. You hear this fucking guy.
He says he's singing all these
Jesus songs. Hang on, hang on.
Okay.
My name is John Dacre.
That's the funniest shit ever.
My name's John Taker. It's
like he's watching his life,
like he already died
and then he came back
and he just got to like,
he first time you ever realized my
name. My name is John Dager. Yeah. Okay.
That's my fucking name.
And this is my life and I'm on TV
and I'm going to sing this song.
This is what I did with
my life. And these,
you look at the guy fucking poor bastard.
Um, anyways,
it's d a k. E. R.
If you're just listening now and you
want to fucking watch it at work,
um Oh my God. Listen to
him sing ally Lou. Yeah.
Oh Man.
[inaudible]
okay. A debit for the grace of God.
This fucking guy would be the
most interesting interview
ever. Just like [inaudible].
He's one of the most fascinating
people I've ever seen. Like what?
What is going on in between
those fucking ears right now?
[inaudible] if they could, if you could
make a show about his fucking thoughts,
you know, all these fucking
movies. Oh, it's, yeah. You know,
they show the movie, but
it's done in reverse.
And then they tried to
fucking flip you out. Nothing.
Nothing pink Floyd could ever fucking
write can match what's going on in this
guy's head. Highly recommended.
All right, let's read 'em.
Let's read some a little bit.
A average size in the, um,
bells will ring. Ring a Ding.
A ding. That's a Maurer.
Um, what the fuck is the God
damn, my name is John Taker.
All right. Oh, Mian d SMI, yon Ds.
No more sweaty taint.
[inaudible] me on d says so dry.
You're gonna Faint and fall into
a puddle Dick fucking first.
But don't fucking worry. Your
underwear will absorb it.
Just like one of those pamper commercials.
Throw it in to the ocean. Oh yeah.
And kill a bunch of fucking dolphins.
All right. Mandy's everybody,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours
a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes, your pro,
your underwear is probably boring
beyond his is here to change that.
Uh, every pair of Mandy's is made
from sustainably sourced modal,
modal [inaudible]. I'm going
to keep saying this and t,
tell me which one to accent,
right? It's like a one syllable
word like bike, you know,
bicycle. It's on the sick.
Right? Or is it on the bike?
Oh, fucking know. Anyways,
every pair of Mandy's is made
from sustainably source mortal.
Oh, I heard woo.
Oh, fabric. That's twice as soft
as cotton. I'll tell you right now,
John Draker didn't have on me on
this. Even if he did not even modal,
could fucking absorb the sweat
pouring down his fucking balls.
Nothing can describe the fit the fields
of me undies feel feeling me on this.
I don't want you to try him on.
Yo understand while they are called the
world's most comfortable underwear, uh,
please, if somebody,
the Illuminati probably has boxes made
out of an endangered species, right?
Baby Seal fucking briefs. And if you
don't love your first pair of me on these,
they're free. No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear.
Some freaks going to collect those,
whether anyone sees them or not.
Remember Superman I'm shipping
is free in the U S and Canada.
And you can save up to $8 a
pair with me undies. What the,
meet the me on these subscription plan.
Get the subscription
plan or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you
go to [inaudible] dot com slash birth
that's me, undies.com/burr
for 20% off your first order.
First Order Mandy's dot com so far. All
right, so all his shave club over there,
um, people, uh,
dollar shave club really appreciates
you buying all this shit.
Um, I don't read this
stuff when they say I,
I dollar shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your goddamn door for a
third of the price of what the
greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you join
dollar Shave Club, you,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. Uh,
you can get a fresh shave first-class
shave whenever you use the executive blade
and that's without even
hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive
with their Dr Covey's easy shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter
carver's shave butter,
the blade gently glides across your
face for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter isn't your average shape
for foam cream. Yeah, shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now is a great time to
join dollar shave club.
New members who buy a
tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the
executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today. Today.
Today it's available by
going to dollar shave
club.com/bar that's dollar shave
club.com/bar Oh, here's another one.
Legal Zoom, everyone. Yeah, let's get
these other way. All right. Legal Zoom.
I'm attention to detail is
critical. When you own a business.
That's why you should use legal zoom.
They can take care of the legal details
so you can focus on growing your
business. You already know legal zoom
is a great way to start your business.
They've helped over a million
people get set up the right way,
not the wrong way, the right way.
There's more to running your business
than getting static supplier and customer
contracts come with the territory
and if you need to hire help,
each state has its own employment
laws. What a pain in the ass there.
Don't spend valuable time researching
the laws and reading print.
Let legal zoom handle that part.
They have a network of
independent attorneys licensed
in 48 states who know your
local laws and regulations.
They'll provide the legal answers
for your day to day questions.
The best part is you don't pay by the
hour since legal zoom is in a law firm.
Instead, you pay a low monthly fee and
know exactly what you're getting upfront.
So go to legalzoom.com today and spend
your time growing your business instead
of worrying about legal
details. Use B U r R. Burn the
box@checkouttosaveevenmoreatlegalzoom.com
I don't get why they say, well,
we're not a law firm,
but we're going to give legal advice and
we're not going to charge by the hour
like lawyers do, but we have a
team of lawyers, I don't know,
fucking zigzagging all over
the track. They're all right.
stamps.com a trips to the post office
have become second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing
your mailing and shipping that way for
so long, but think about all the
hassles, man. Dropping what you're doing,
driving there, finding parking, parking,
getting stared at at the cereal
place by some Weirdo with dyed hair,
despite the fact he's bald.
There's a much better way.
stamps.com stamps.com
is easy and convenient.
Way To get posters right from your desk
buying print official us postage using
your own computer and printer with
stamps.com there's no guesswork.
They make it easy to exact posts to
get the exact postage for any letter,
any package, any class a
mail, the instinct you need
it. No expensive postage,
meters to lease and no more trips to
the post office. You gotta try it.
I use stamps.com to send out all my
posters whenever I'm whoring myself out
after shows.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name [inaudible] for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes a postage and a digital
scale. So don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
your baby's going to cry. Don't worry
about it. Just go on to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstamps.com
enter
bar.
All
right,
got it out of the fucking way. Here
we go. Let's get back to the podcast.
Um, all right, let's read some
of the letters for this week.
We're going to lead some of the rent.
Oh, before, before I do though, the uh,
Jesus Christ, poor Jason
Law head man after game one.
He's a Cleveland Guy after game
one and I can't even say game on.
After the first fucking quarter,
this guy was sending me texts.
He had his like his head in the
oven. I'm like, Jesus Christ, Dude.
Nobody fucking throws in
the towel the way you did.
I remember back to back years,
I think in 84 the Lakers came out and
blew out the Celtics in game one and we
came back and beat him and then the very
next year we blew them out and game one
one by like 1520 fucking points. And
then the Lakers won. So I was like,
for fuck sakes. The Bruins
were down out to the Vancouver.
We ended up winning for the
next five and we raised,
we fucking hoisted up the cup.
Stop being such a negative Nelly.
And then after the game too, when
they lost by like fucking 30 or 35,
I wrote back to him, I maybe
you've got a point. Yeah.
Um, I never say this after two games,
but this series is fucking over.
It's over man. Just go, go down. If you
live in Oakland, just go fucking find a,
uh, you know, find a good spot for the
championship parade. This, this is a,
I don't know, maybe they go back
to Cleveland and then, you know,
all the positivity from
their fans seeps into,
I'm kidding. Um, here's a
question I got. If you guys,
I didn't get why Trump got into
so much fucking trouble. You know,
I, we, you know what I
know, cause he's a dope,
but like this stuff that they were
saying that he said something racist,
right about the uh, the judge
Mexican American judge, right?
Something about the fucking
wall. This is what I like to do.
And on a hot button issue like this,
I just gonna Wade right in with
barely ever even knowing the facts.
It says Donald Trump's attacks
on the judge, uh, are racist.
He's quite literally saying the judge
can't do his job because of his ethnicity.
This is the definition of racism. I guess.
He was doing some debate going on about
that wall that he wants to build and
this judge who's Mexican
American was going to rule on it.
And I think Trump said that he didn't
want him to because he was Mexican.
He was going to be biased. So
everybody said that that was racist.
So here's my question. As a Joe 12 pack,
I'm not Joe six pack Joe 12 pack. Um,
basically what he did there is far as
I could tell is how they picked juries.
Isn't that how they always pick
a jury? You know what I mean?
Like if you go down for jury duty and
the defendant is black as a white dude,
yet the, I'm not, I'm not going to
get picked for this jury or the, the,
the defending defendant, uh,
attorney doesn't want me on there.
Right? Isn't that how they picked the
whole old jets? How they always do it?
If it's a domestic violence case,
let's try to get as many women
there as possible. You know,
I think they hide it by go because I
think that they can understand women also
now they're hoping to
win the fucking case.
So what they do is they stack the deck
with enough people of the same ilk as the
defendant right now. Don't they
do that? Yeah. My nuts here,
I believe that that's what they do. So
I thought it was kind of ironic that they
within the court system that if Trump
is saying that,
it's like Trump's picking his Gerry to
try to get the fucking wall and what he
wants is he wants a bunch of fucking
white people who like a white guy goes,
oh, we'll [inaudible] you. You, you,
you watch how great it's going to be.
He wants the mouth breathing
morons that like him on his jury.
That's all he was saying as
far as I could tell. Right.
Not saying the guy's not racist,
but I thought that that one,
they were stretching
the bounds a little bit.
Now I'm just asking a fucking question
before you fucking edit this thing and
make me look like the next Hitler.
But I was watching that story.
I was just going like, yeah,
that's kind of how courts work.
It's kind of exactly how it works.
And not to mention when
the OJ verdict came in,
white people like what the fuck and
black people were freaking out having a
parade. That's why they do it. Right?
Everybody watches it and you put yourself
in the position of whatever's there.
I watched the OJ trial, I'm fucking,
I got my throat slashed. Right?
Black people watch it and they go, yeah,
I got off. That's how I look at it.
I Dunno. And I don't
think that's wrong either.
It's like watching sports except
it's people's freedom. Um, Eddie.
Alright. Scandinavia. Hey
Billy Burger balls. Uh,
is it true that you're not
going to come to Scandinavia?
Me and my lady are huge fans and was
really hoping for you to come to Sweden
this summer. Slash. Fall.
I just need to know if I need to book
some plane tickets to the Netherlands,
then this is going to cost me like
one grand for us to see your shit.
But I'll bet it's worth it. A,
but I just need to know if you're planning
to come to Scandinavia some point in
the future.
Otherwise love your shit and looking
forward to F is for family season to,
well thank you very much. Um,
F is for family season two is the reason
why on this trip I'm not going to a
Scandinavia. So like
there's like three chunks.
Okay. There's the my pasty
people, which is coming in first.
You know, just like the jury
does this mean I'm a, I'm a,
I'm a racist the way I'm touring
against other white people. Um, no,
it's just how it worked up.
And then I probably would do the
Scandinavian thing next and then
hopefully eastern Europe. That's
what I am hoping to do. Um,
the show takes up way more time than
I thought it would, but like they,
I had a list of 29 cities that wanted
to bring me over there and I could have
gone on a month long
fucking crazy ass tour. Um,
uh, broken it up into two. But I
think the way my workload is now,
I have to break it into three, but like
I am absolutely coming back there again.
It's a beautiful country.
Um, I love it. You know,
the fuck doesn't want to go that I've
been in like two or three times and uh,
I'll definitely come back.
I just don't know when, um,
I can't promise you as to when, but I am
definitely going to come back and, uh,
I don't know. Other than that, I
don't have any more information.
So save you money, dude.
Don't blow a grant.
Don't blow grant coming to see
me with Shit and Dick Jokes.
I'll, I'll, I'll come your way. All
right. Don't worry about it. Okay.
Ex men billboard. Hey billion. Um,
this is fucking nerd shit. A nerd
shit. So please bear with me.
There's a new x man
movie and Rose McGowan,
the chick who used to date Marilyn Manson
has their tits in an uproar over this
billboard because between
mystique a woman and apocalypse,
that dude, if you don't want to click
on the link from some Weirdo, you don't,
don't know a no problem.
Just to picture just picture of blue
dude holding up a naked blue woman by the
throat to the point or feet aren't
on the ground. Context. Apocalypse.
The dude is a bad ass villain
in the movie and Mystique.
The woman is the leading lady and
Badass heroin in the movie. Um,
here's the problem. Rose McGowan says,
this is promoting violence against women,
which I feel is horse shit. Here's why.
If it was Hugh Jackman Slash Wolverine
being choked out and held up,
no problem.
The point of the post is to show how
dangerous slash how much of a threat the
villain, how much of a threat the villain
is. It's not a political statement.
Here's my issue with this though.
How does this studio slash movie maker
when Suppose Wolverine was the leading
hero? It was a one,
women would be con women
would be complaining that
it's always a man as the hero
and women are more like backup
or support roles. I mean,
Ms Mystique is bad ass. She's
leading the fight against this guy.
To me that's empowering to women.
Uh, she is in a sex symbol.
In the movie though, Jennifer Lawrence,
who plays her is really attractive.
She's just strong and a leader.
All I can think is that they
wanted her standing all,
all I can think is that they want her
standing on the neck of the villain.
But this, but that's fucking
stupid. For promotional posters.
You couldn't have her be the villain
and holding up a man hero because that
would be some kind of anti woman. All
women are evil campaign instead. Right.
Where you lost me here,
you couldn't have her be the villain
and holding up a man hero. Oh,
I see. If she, if,
if the female character was evil and
there was holding up the guy character,
they couldn't do that because
then they would be saying, oh,
if we antique be considered
anti-women all women are evil. Um,
I guess what bothers me is that it just
seems like there's no way to please any
non white male. Lately, uh, women wanted
a strong female hero that got one,
but she's in danger of the villain. A man,
somehow that equals violence on women
when it's really just about violence in
general or war or conflict
or whatever. I mean,
the dude isn't slapping her
for over cooking his steak.
He's trying to conquer the
world. She's trying to stop,
stop him and he's choking her ass.
How, how is that a gender issue?
Um, all right. Uh, let me see. Let me
see. If I can find the picture this year,
I did look at it, uh,
[inaudible] library. No, that's not
the f I always click on the wrong one.
Okay.
Yeah. I actually, you know, when I
heard it, I thought it was bull shit,
but then I saw the poster,
the, the movie clip that I saw.
I don't see your feet
dangling off of it. Um, I,
I see why they did that. I understand
why that they did it that way.
What happens is when you're writing,
what I'm learning is when you're writing
something you're so fucking focused on
is the story tracking from point a to
point B to point c and we land this thing
without crashing into
the fucking ocean. Um,
that they wouldn't think that anybody,
you know, might have a problem with that.
Um, I understand, I understand. I,
this is actually one of those ones I
get why they don't want to see that,
but in defensive view, if, how about this?
If the guy character, the, the fucking
Apollo Guy, whatever his fucking name is,
was a apocalypse, such dumb names,
apocalypse mystique, this
all sound like bad cologne.
Um,
okay.
Um, anyways, if, if
apocalypse was holding a,
the Wolverine Hugh Jackman
by the throat, now,
would that be promoting
male on male violence?
Would that be more a barroom
brawls because of that?
I honestly don't think
it promotes violence.
I think, um,
like the levels stupid that you'd have
to be to look at apocalypse holding up,
pulled in a woman by her
throat and to say like, oh,
I guess it's okay to hit women. Now
I'm going to start hitting women.
If you were that fucking stupid,
by the time you got to you,
unless she was riding
in the car, let's see,
you're driving home and now you're going
to fucking choker because you saw this
apocalypse guy choking a fucking, um,
mystique, right?
You'd also see another thousand signs
on the way home and next thing you know,
I dunno, you'd be in a car
dealership buying something or, uh,
getting a fucking McDonald's sandwich.
I think you would forget you with that.
Like, if your brain was
like that, uh, influenced,
but having said that, I looking at
the, um, the poster and I don't,
I understand why they would just
like, you know, that's not the, uh,
greatest image. You could have
another image up there. Yeah.
I don't have a problem with them changing
it, but I definitely understand your,
um, your points on that thing. But,
uh, you know, I don't, I don't,
I don't fucking know. It's, it's
just the time that we're living in.
Everybody gets offended.
Everybody doesn't get offended.
A small group of people gets
offended. And, um, the news covers,
you know, because what are they
gonna talk about the fucking,
now the drug companies in a roundabout
way killed prince, you know,
I mean, what are they
gonna talk about it again?
Talk about fracking and people
than fucking up the water supply.
Then there's too much money involved
in that. Okay. But you know,
if you've got a group of fucking soccer
moms upset about a fucking blue woman
getting held up by a guy who appears to
be made out of stone, I'm in a movie,
you know, that's gonna make
it. It's gonna make it,
you do a Caitlin Jenner joke
in a fucking strip mall. Yeah,
that's going to get on the fucking
news. But real shit that matters. Nah,
that's not gonna happen. You know,
that's not going to fall. Why? Why now?
Why would you do that?
That's just another one of
those backburner stories
that they just stick on the
front burner all the fucking time.
Like they, I mean, I'm not saying like,
you know, violence against women isn't
a major issue, but I'm just saying like,
people aren't as simplistic as that.
Like they don't fucking
look at something and like,
um,
I dunno as a kid,
like the amount of violence that
I watched when I was growing up,
you know what I mean? All the
fucking shows that I've watched,
I've yet to chase somebody down an
alley, pull them off a fence, chain link,
fence, beat them up. Or even
slide over the hood of a car.
I saw all those images
when I was growing up.
I used to pretend and play
war and all that shit.
I never fucking killed anybody. I've never
hit a woman. I never did any of that.
I think what, you know, what it is,
is what really makes you do shit like
that is his horrific fucking parents.
I think that that's what it is. And
now they're trying to blame the signs,
the sign that's going to be up for all
of fucking two weeks when this movie's
out,
as opposed to your dad and mom and their
relationship that you grow up for the
first 18 years of your life.
Fucking watch it. But you know,
you can't blame those people because
those people buy things on the channel.
You know what I mean?
So you always give them a pass and then
you rub their balls and you call them
Joe six back in fucking, uh,
the true heroes. You know,
they're always rubbing their balls like
they give a fuck about them. They don't,
they just want their money.
You know what I mean?
That's why corporations act like all of
these non crisis is our absolute crisis
crisis disease, because they
don't want to lose a fucking dime.
So if anybody bitches, anybody mounds,
anybody complains, they fucking cave in.
And then a lot of these groups are
aware of that. And when they get to a,
to get a corporation to
cave, it gives them like it,
it's almost like a video game.
It gives them more life and a,
they're taken more seriously. So it's
a giant, it's a giant fucking game.
You know, at the end
of the day it's, it's,
it's two people that
don't fucking exist. But
um,
I dunno, there's something,
there's a look on her face.
She doesn't look bad ass there.
It makes me feel bad for
her and I want to help her.
So maybe what they should have done,
she should've had a more fucking Rhonda
Rousey look on her face and maybe it was
pulling backs on his
fucking, are those cornrows?
What the fuck does he have?
Or is that wavy hair? I can't,
I don't know what this guy made
out of his fucking claymation hair.
She should have. She
should be like, you know,
maybe gouge in his eyes a little
bit. I don't know. I was kidding who.
They'd still fucking complain.
Um,
if you really want to get them going,
just have that picture right there.
That image. Nah,
I'm not going to tell you to do that
because there's no sense of humor anymore.
I was gonna I was going to say that maybe
you could take that image and say like
, um, no, don't built down it's,
it's don't ask me in a show. I'll tell
you what I was going to say. All right.
Hey, Billy dope, Philly, the fucking dope.
Can't can women forget Mr.
Nice Guy Persona. Uh, Hey,
I'm really having a difficult reading
today. All right, big fan from Lithuania.
That's another one on the list that I
gotta get to. Uh, you're a great comedian.
It would be great if he ever decided to
do your stand up here in the Baltics.
Um, that will happen at
some point in my career.
Hopefully sooner rather than
later. All right. The guy says,
I got at this dilemma. Can a woman
forget your past as a nice guy?
One of my former classmates is coming
back to my hometown on summer vacation for
a few weeks and let's say I'd like to
get intimate with her while she's here.
Now the thing is, when
we were still in school,
I had a mad crush on this
girl for years. However,
Shit didn't work out because I
didn't know how the life works,
how the females work. And also I
was a little bitch, Mister Nice guy.
Uh,
I beat my younger self. That
was possible. All right.
[inaudible] you're doing some good therapy
here. Uh, but for over the years, uh,
but over the years that I've
spent in our capital city city,
I can safely say that my view and
attitude towards females and masculinity,
Lee masculinity has changed
significantly. What do you think?
Can a woman brush off the image of a nice
guy or are you forever marked with the
certain character traits in her eyes? Um,
yeah, I think you're,
you're kind of fucked.
Just put it this way.
Like take like the actor that played
like Urkel or something like that.
It's like you're typecast, you know,
and Urkel could literally become an
army fucking ranger and then leave the
military. And when he went to
go do a fucking action movie,
they allow fucking article.
Give me a fucking break. Right.
It's just the problem is
what you got to do. Look,
you always got to take you
go, he's gotta take it.
Bet what you're going to have to
do when you get up there. He says,
you're going to have to crowd the
plate. No Kid, which I would just be,
you're gonna have to be significantly
different to raise any sort of intrigue in
her. You know what I mean? Cause
probably just wants to meet up with you,
you know, have a couple of
ciders or whatever that,
whatever those drinks women have,
when they know that they're not
going to fuck you. You know,
one of those fucking, I
want to feel warm. You know,
they have that stupid sweater that covers
their hands too and they drink it with
both hands out of a Mug, you know?
And it's just fucking over, right.
They're like, you know, hitting more
on the waiter than the, I don't,
I mean listen to you. You're
going to have to lie. I Dunno.
I don't know what you gotta do.
Go Buy yourself a Raiders of
the lost Ark Leather jacket.
You got to try to come in and act
like you've been fucking doing this.
This is the thing.
This is what's gonna fuck you is you
want this woman to bad. All right?
You got to not give a fuck.
Don't be, don't be a deck.
But just go in there and just,
hey, what's going on? What?
Even up to now and then talk up some
of the shit you're doing. You know?
I don't know. Look at your phone out
his bride. She's driving me crazy.
I got the ladies all over me. I
don't know. I don't know dude.
I don't know what to tell you on
this one. Once you're typecast,
it's fucking over, dude. You got
to go behind the camera here.
You got to start directing or some shit
cause I don't know what to tell you.
Your, um, this is what I would
do. Just know this going into it,
you're fucked. All right. So there's
no pressure. Who gives a shit?
And uh, I don't know. Make her
laugh and just tell her, you know,
I always had a crush on you,
but I used to be a bitch,
but I'm not a bitch anymore. So
what do you say? What do you say?
You come over here and uh, jump on my
fucking enough. He can't go that way,
but I, yeah, I would, I'm man, man,
that's a tough one. That's a tough
one. I, I, you know, maybe that's it.
Just trash your former self. Yeah. Used
to be. It used to be a pitch, you know,
I don't know how to do
it, dude. You know what?
You'd get stumped me
somewhere in there, I think.
I think the whole not giving a fuck and
then trashing your former self and then
just telling her that you had a crush
on her. Who knows? Dude, maybe. Uh,
I dunno. There's a chance. Maybe
she likes you back then or, I dunno.
Women got that thing though, Dude. Once
you're the fucking friend, it, you're,
you're, you're, it's over.
Dude. So you're fucking, um,
oh, the lovely Nia Nia.
You know, we need you,
me and this guy from Lithuania. I'll
tell you really quickly, grab up,
grab one of those chords.
All right. Jesus. All right.
As you're plugging in, I'll tell you
this guy basically in Lithuania, he, uh,
he used to be a bitch when it
used to be Mr. Nice guy. So he,
he didn't get any of any of the nice,
nicest Tracy Morgan would say. Right.
So he, um,
whatever he had a crush on
this chicken she got put in.
The friend zone is Chris Rock would say,
I'm just going to quote every
black comedian here and um,
you plugged in. There we go. And
you're putting the windscreen on eh,
really loud and annoying to the
listeners. There we go. The lovely Nia.
Everybody. Hi. Yeah. So basically
he had a crush on this girl.
He was a nice guy.
He got put in the friend zone and
now she's coming back to town.
He's now lived in the city. He understands
the male female dynamic better.
Okay. And, um, the way he's wearing this,
he's been doing all right for himself,
but he still wants to
bang this woman. He's, he,
his question is once you're in the
friend zone like that [inaudible] okay.
Is it possible to get out of it?
Absolutely. It is. Oh Wow. Okay.
Cause I was going like, I don't
know, I was saying to you like, type,
you're like Urkel and now you want
to be the star of an action movie,
you know? But yeah, no, I
think you can, but it's all,
it's all predicated on your behavior.
Like you don't want gotta
all of a sudden start at
do you like an aloof, a
jerk or anything like that.
So I told them by a rate as a lost
dark waste link, leather jacket,
maybe get it hat and a whip. Oh yeah.
Is that bad? Uh, I just,
I think maybe you're a little
less available perhaps.
You know, you know, it can be a thing
where she'll come to town and be like,
oh my God, I guess let's go here and
Dah, Dah, Dah, and I want to do this.
And then, you know. Oh yeah,
yeah, definitely. Well, we'll,
we'll let me know when
you're around. Yeah.
Maybe we can grab a drink or
something. Gave a cash and um,
don't go in there like, so I've
been fucking a lot of broads. Yeah.
It's not like that,
but just as she's talking about her
life, you talk about your life. Yeah.
I've been seeing
girls here and there. I don't
know nothing too serious,
but I've been having my fun. But
anyway, what's going on with you?
You look good like that. Like
Nia, Bam. That was good.
Oh, were you, were you,
were you enjoying that just then that
little ah, interact. I am joining the,
the the advice. Yeah, that was good.
That was usually, I was stammering.
I was like, uh, maybe I have
to just fuck it. I said,
your best thing you got going
is, you know you've got no shot,
so just don't give a fuck it,
just go in there and just be like,
I sold shoes.
You have to not get, you can't go
into it with expectations of anything.
Yeah. I think you just be normal.
Be a friend like you have been,
but I think I have a friend who
often gets friends zoned it,
and I'm always telling him that he needs
to make himself less available because
he always makes himself available
psychologically to women when the less
available as I have a theory and I know
it'll be considered sexist,
so I'll listen to you. Or just
the same with men and women.
If you're less available,
like the PE people want you more.
And I think that's just how life is.
People like the hunt. I think
men like the hunt a little more.
So I think you should
remember like the hunt
really. If someone's like a pain, be
like, oh hey. And I'd be like, yeah,
I'm not a hunter. I
have four of it. Gather.
No, I was just more like, I hate,
hated when women played hard to get. It
was so funny. It just, it got so boring,
so fucking fast. I was just like, Hey,
I can fucking, I'll just go rub one out
and then I'll go watch a game and then
you know something. Then I act. It's,
you're not worth the fucking
trouble. Right. You know what I mean?
I just always found that like, um,
cause I remember when I would just start
to walk away and let these girls would
be like, no, you're supposed to blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. I was like, oh,
I didn't,
I didn't get the script to where my in
like some fucking awful play right now.
Right.
I walked away from a lot by my number
could have been so much higher.
I should've chased. I didn't chase, I
just tapped out. I'd be like, ah, yeah.
You know, if you don't want
to, I understand. You know,
I wouldn't fuck me either.
Oh, all right. Oh No,
don't say that about yourself.
People like you. All right.
A bill dill pickle. Um, I love a
good sandwich. My question to you is,
if you are a sandwich, what
type of sandwich would you be?
I think you already answered this one.
If you could eat only one sandwich for
the rest of your life, what would you be?
All right, Nia. Remind the listeners
what kind of sandwich you think I am.
I once compared you to a
grilled cheese sandwich.
But the thing about it said you were
about as exotic is a grilled cheese
sandwich. I was talking about
that. If, if I ever went to prison,
yes. The fact that I was a red head
on for the first time in my life,
I might be considered exotic. Yeah.
And I thought you were
grossly overestimating.
I was joking about the fact that quickly
I would be sexually assaulted in there.
And you had to remind me
that I'm a plain Jane.
There wasn't even tomatoes on that
fucking grilled cheese sandwich.
You think what? The hair? I
would got something. Fuck.
Alright, so sandwich. Would you
like to eat for the rest of the,
I know the sandwich that I could.
This sounded like this question
came out of cosmo. He went to Tham,
which were kind of thing.
Which would you be,
and if you could only eat one
sandwich for the rest of your life,
what would it be?
We would never ask each other what
kind of sandwich we'd want to be.
Maybe like what kind of dress are
you? A classic little black dress.
The cocktail dress. Oh,
for the Oscars like that.
But what about for the bigger girls? Well,
for the bigger girls where
they see the bigger girls,
or you were car cover with Spaghetti
straps stop. Why didn't they call?
They're just feeding your fucking egos.
Like you're all these PR. Oh yeah.
When I want, I get what they're doing.
They're trying to sell magazines anyway.
What kind of sandwich
would you be? Velveeta.
If I was a pair of pants,
I'd be clam diggers.
I saw like four or five guys
wearing those fucking things. Oh,
this weekend? Yeah. Like those guys.
We have the Hitler youth haircuts and
then they just walk around with the cubes
up the fucking airport.
It's the funniest thing ever.
I don't know why it's not so CIF sackful
just pointed their legs and start
laughing. It's just me. All right.
I love a good sandwich too. Okay.
Um, oh. And I be, uh, I don't
know. My freckles and all that.
I'd probably be a lobster roll.
Lobster or crab roll? No,
you're looking all fucking
white with red blotches
in a day old bun. That'd be my
sciatic nerve problem. I'm a mess.
It's too like there are
certain white people,
they definitely take on the hue of a
boiled lobster when they had to my son.
And that would be me. Um, if you, okay.
Turkey sandwich cause you like Turkey
sandwiches. Yeah. But that's not me.
You're not no Turkey sandwich. You know,
people get excited and happy when Turkey
comes around. You know what I mean?
I think you're a Turkey sandwich
cause you're like, what?
You don't ever say that again? I think
you're a Turkey citizen. You're reliable.
You're satisfied. And when I
talk I make it go to sleep.
When consumed, I make you sleepy. All
right. If you could only eat one sandwich,
Nia, for the rest of your
life, what would it be?
This feels like a lifetime movie. Is a
Philly cheese day considered a sandwich?
Cause you know, that's my all
time favorite of all time.
Well I mean it's not
considered breakfast. No,
it's considered a cereal. All right.
So yeah, I feel like a cheese stick.
I don't remember. Yeah,
hero is a sandwich. Right?
Or whatever the fuck they call a
hero sandwich. So yeah. One Sandwich.
Rest of my life, I'd eat a peanut butter
sandwich with butter. PBB and Jay.
Yeah, that's what I would have with
a glass of fucking milk weight.
You'd have jelly on it though. What
do you know? I don't wanna get fat.
You put Jelly on your fucking with
you. If I could have one once,
just one for the rest of my fucking
life. I don't have to eat it every day.
Well, no, not every day,
but the only sandwich when you're
in the mood for a sandwich,
you can only eat this particular sandwich.
I Dunno. An Italian sub.
You like Italian sandwiches.
Then they put the oil all over and
it feels like the bread sweaty.
You don't always have to get the oil.
I don't know what I'd have. I don't, I
don't know what I would fucking have.
It is just to my not, I guess if
I wouldn't die of a heart attack,
I'd have a roast beef sandwich.
Here you go. There you go, Bill.
You're exciting. All right,
lady likes the belly. Uh,
Billy, you bastard, love the podcast.
It's just funny you passed
it. Love the podcast mate. Um,
have been following your
shenanigans for nearly eight years,
hustling for tickets when
you get here to London.
I got my birthday on the 3rd of August
and we'll be cruising through to your gig
on the fifth.
Caught you a couple of years ago and
gave you a cigar after the show with the
roundhouse in Camden. Who knows, maybe
you smoked it. Of course I did. Okay,
so help me with this kind of weird
dilemma of mine. Here's the deal. I'm six,
two, six, three. On a good day, if
he's feeling good about himself,
he stands up straight and
I'm fairly trim. However,
due to my love of cake pie and
all the things donut I've packed,
I've packed on a mass in one
specific area. My belly. Oh God.
That's the classic European
fucking body, you know? Yeah.
They got those seventh grader arms and
then they just got the fucking fish and
chips belly. Like they're
generally a thinner people,
but they like their pubs
and they like, yeah,
thin or cause I think their
food is higher quality,
but they just don't go to the gym over
there. They walk around a lot though.
All right. My brother loves it. Um,
they've nicknamed me big belly
Bigsby a callback to Chappelle's,
Clayton Bigsby and I've become used to,
used to giving it a good old
fashioned slap from time to time.
My lady loves it too. She rubs it,
wants to fill up with her rabbit food,
a, she's Vegan, whatever, et Cetera,
et cetera. It's a mind fuck subverts.
The whole guy's got to have a pack
vibe. You're losing me here anyways,
I'm gonna keep on going Michelangelo on
this bitch and getting into shape at the
risk of losing the fail safe laughter
of the day. What do you think?
Yeah, dude,
you don't want to be the fat guy who
slaps his belly like a fucking walrus
looking for a mate.
And if you don't get it under control,
it's going to get bigger and bigger and
it's going to be bad for your health.
So trust me, your girlfriend
might love the belly right now,
but she's going to really
love that six back.
Oh, really? What if she's insecure?
She's worried that he's going
to go out and fucking start,
do the full Monty someplace,
both work and get the six back together.
Although she might already have it since
she's a Vegan and obviously [inaudible]
happens and to keep what couples could
never work out. I don't like, yeah,
I'm not into it. But remember when we
tried to work out and I was just yelling,
you push it out, you know? No,
we never worked out together like
that. We would go to the gym together.
Then we separate your thing. And I
would always, do we go do a party?
What do we do? We go in different
graphs. Words. Yeah. Yeah.
I came here to have a
good time. Not to be,
got to be with the person I live with.
[inaudible] I came here. I live with you.
I don't need to hang out
with you at this part.
So what's going on with you in this
new environment? Um, all right.
I got to know your girlfriend's
gonna love the six bag,
so keep at it and like to keep a belly
just so people can slap it around so you
can be that guy at the party after
a while. Yeah, that's pathetic.
It's better to get shredded and
be, you know, real Michelangelo.
Yeah. And then you get to walk around
being a Dick, being aloof, you know,
you just, every time people talk to you,
you pretend you're looking at something
down the street with your fucking
eyebrows up. Sorry man. I just
gotta keep on moving. You know,
I'm like a shark. Did you
talk about that poster?
Ah, yeah. Yeah, I missed it. Yeah.
The guy actually brought up a bunch
of great points, which is, oh,
I don't know if you want to go
back and read it. Um, I can't,
I don't remember. He was just saying
like, well no and 50 was like, Whoa,
here's one that I made it. If
he was holding up Hugh Jackman,
would that increase the chances
of guys fighting other guys?
I don't think it's about like increasing
like influencing people to do what?
It's just like, it's just not against.
It isn't a great look. I actually,
I don't think that it's a good poster,
but I would say that I don't think it
promotes violence against women. I don't,
I wouldn't think so either.
But although I'm not trying to speak
for blue women though. That's right.
They can speak for
themselves. No, I don't know.
I saw that poster and I first of
all couldn't tell it was a woman,
but if I was like well versed in
that whole thing, I would be like,
oh that's such and such character.
Uh, yeah, I don't, I dunno.
But I think it's probably best
that they, they're all in the,
all the different poster I was saying.
They're all named after like
discontinued. Um, colognes. I'm like,
what mystique apocalypse just sounds like.
It's like whoever came up with Zima than
tried to get into Cologne and it all
fucking bombed. Right. Listen,
I unfortunately got to stop the podcast
cause I got to go to work. Boom,
boom Boba [inaudible]. All right.
Thank you guys for listening.
And, um, I'll let you guys
know about those Presales, um,
for the upcoming dates in Ireland and, uh,
thank you to everybody that's
been buying tickets in Scotland,
in Amsterdam and London, and a second
show in London, Nini. That's so great.
Yeah. But I found this a Gaba where
I can fucking smoke a stick after.
I love that nice big picture
of fucking, I don't know,
Winston Churchill or some shit would
be wonderful. Right? I don't know, Nan,
we have, I don't ever say we never
shout out. Is that Winston Churchill?
It's already made. All right.
With Winston Churchill in front,
I think ace is high. I believe that
was all right. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on your Thursday.